there are you kids we're gonna make it
to listen for da da right you kids
it's not well-suited for the survival
level to determine bodies blasts Ryder
Oh rocket doubts ah Wow I am to bow for
you my murder machine finally came in
today oh boy
Oh No yeah I'm still alive I'll be it
only slightly
Oh pish I am now good Sarge we're gonna
try the skin wait why have I let what
why did I let go the bike yeah can I
kill them press up in way what's this up
and laughs sure ah oh it worked how did
that work
ha ah you only hit my gut it did not
hurt this is quite interesting but at
the same time oh oh oh da fuk da ba okay
up left up left and there we go ah right
into my skull that's not even fair again
into the face you dick one more try
different
haha yogurt video haha oh you missed me
haha little kid oh you dropped your axe
ha ha ha you missed me old man
ah ha Bisky ah ok let's try this again
okay there you go
excuse me old man your blood will be the
lubricant for my climb not anything else
shut up you're all oh I'd hurt ah ha ha
yes who is the pro now one-armed as I
maybe you are wish you're as cool as me
Jack apesh spyro spiral the not reading
that my god this is amazing
you love o God
instructions Possible's aa challenge
welcome welcome welcome into the blue
wish anima ace on my face in a pogo
stick
hello Oh is something going to happen
Wow okay haha oh come on I was right
there okay let's try this again
don't kill yourself why are you Joe not
my sword my sword I'll tell you with
this watermelon [ __ ] now I'll do like
that fruit yeah oh my dog I'm stabbing
your watermelon with my ding-dong not
our euphemism okay
just got a chunky chunky chunky monkey
ha ha ha oh come on I was gonna get it
impossible Yeah right
ha ha that barely even hurt me hurt yeah
come on come over here we go oh hey back
up this a bit peddlers cakes Oh again
with the face Robert I'm yeah brisk oh
there we go
now with the proper angle I can
appropriately physics wrong ball through
little Club the paper yes I got two
balls huh damn ax well I got blue
garbage can I did not help me unlock
victory
yes victory line give me a ball the
victory mine victory mine oh yeah barbar
women
wait a minute you kids what wha Santa
Claus knows my prison its misery it's
not I need more time alright goodbye
damn blitz Gerber car ah sword throw one
just one wait how do I even grab it it's
too far
God can't bend the knees okay oh oh I
see
my hand yep whoa Oh extremely impossible
oh yeah
four try wait hang on first try
oh come on oh come on backwards you dick
don't get him in the damn it damn it
second try what yeah all my nards on my
head on my ass it is the trick it's a
tricky - hey thank you for banging his
head on the ground - you dick
sir try wait wait this is a bottle run
cuz what are we doing on a bottle run
you all cursed go do it no poor try yeah
oh my god yeah duh No oh yeah all wait
that's good
test your neck oh this is good bad all
right kids
I forgot a dog ball run we're going to
it right oh this is this is not good
look at the goiter that forms around his
neck area god no that's the wrong way
what that way dude this is my death ball
why are you rolling only up what we're
doing there we go
this has been happy wheels highlights
thanks for watching if you like what you
saw and you want to see more why not
subscribe to my channel want to help the
channel grow
leave a like add it to your favorites or
share it with your friends on Facebook
and Twitter thanks again and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Music]